(chime)
- [Kelly Clarkson] We have to
find something related to you.
Okay. Find something related!
- What does that mean?
What does that mean?
- [Kelly Clarkson]
Metaphorically or physically.
- [Anna Kendrick] Wait, wait, wait.
- [Justin Timberlake]
This is not... I mean...
- Does this count as related to me?
- Boom.
(exclaim in unison)
- Oh, look at what we just did!
- I stole my kid's toy.
(laughs)
- Oh you did, you stole your kid's...
I got one better than
that, I stole my kid.
(laughs)
- Oh.
- [Kelly Clarkson] This is River.
- Kelly wins again, hi!
- Oh hey, come here.
They were about to head
out with our nanny.
So come here.
This is Remi.
We were just watching Trolls.
This is Branch and this is Poppy.
- Hi.
- Can you say hi?
- Okay.
Ya'll look like, you did your hair man?
Okay, somebody thought they
were gonna be on camera, okay.
Hey, can you say bye to them?
- Bye.
- Do you like trolls?
- [Remi] Uh huh.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You love trolls.
- And I love your acting.
I love Poppy and the prince.
- And Branch.
(laughs)
- Oh my gosh.
(kids talk over each other)
- All right, were you kind of worried
that mommy was gonna be a mean troll?
Yeah?
- [Kids] No.
- Okay.
Later guys, okay.
All right, so...
Sorry, something related to you.
What did you get, Anna?
- I got Poppy.
- Oh my god you both brought your...
(Kelly laughs)
- It's the first thing...
- I was like it's related to
me, nobody's in the house.
- That's awesome, that relates to you.
There you go, this was
perfect, that's amazing.